wesley saw literally jumping out of his
seat to analyze some more chess here
with us
wesley first of all congratulations on
your overall performance in the grand
chess tour you got second place how do
you feel
well first of all uh thanks for having
me and the reason why i want to look at
other players games because i played so
bad that
i want to look at other games and not
mine
but
i mean of course second place it's not
bad but
after what i did yesterday i mean it was
probably one of my biggest choke
choker and my history of choking which
happens quite a lot
tell us about yesterday what what
happened you saw yourself
shortly with a huge attack
yeah i mean the problem i guess is first
of all
i was probably preparing too much
between my games like i had two rest
days in this tournament and i was
preparing like a few hours
during those rest days probably never a
good idea because you consume a lot of
energy then you can get a good position
on the board but preparation cannot
really win you games and
i think fiordia was playing badly in the
beginning
and
i surprised him in the opening because i
never played this a6a5 blind before
so
i had no problems after i played knight
h5 i was very happy
um obviously i just didn't want to lose
the game
because it's practically
uh guarantees winning the grand chester
if i drew yesterday
um
so when playing knight h5 with f6
i
was just trying to play risk-free but i
couldn't exactly understand what's
happening like i think
alireza played very well practically
like he played knights he takes e5 very
quickly in this position here yeah
like i thought
his position is super suspicious
but at the same time he took on e5 very
confidently so that kind of
confused me a little bit so
psychologically a little impact there
yeah i think
i must say i have big respect for
alireza i hope he
becomes the world champion one day i'm
very impressed with his play so far
winning st louis rapid and blitz and
he's only
19 years old so i think
possibly he would be the best player of
his generation
on his age i mean some people like him
some people don't i i for one i like
watching his games what do you mean what
some people don't what do they don't
like about his chess
well also the
personality and all that like if a new
the new player on the block it's a
little bit jealous
you've got little quirks like
i
i you know i know people in the chess
world and
some people just don't know him very
well also he switched federation
to france recently
and he has
little quirks here and there during
tournaments like like for example
um
he doesn't have a good relationship with
the wycombe say tournament right now or
also some organizers but
i guess the game is what
matters the most and he's number four in
the world and uh i think he's very
strong he
still has a lot of weaknesses currently
but nothing that can't be fixed and he's
only 19.
so uh
i'm
very impressed with him and i think
magnus is as well but i think in this
tournament he has several suspicious
positions like he played very well the
rapping blitz but in the classical
uh he made quite a lot of arrows like he
was losing against shaq
and i think he has
was losing yesterday
and
he wasn't really able to put much
pressure in the opening but
but
um as i said he played knights he takes
e5 very quickly so uh
he's he calculates really well and he
makes very good practical decisions but
anyway after bishop hr knight d3 i saw
i saw the winning line like
i thought rook 88 and then only move
knight d4
queen g6
yeah the the problem with the
grandchild store tournaments is that you
can never oh you guess you can't move
huh i'm not sure why
yeah because your brows oh you have to
click creation practice
oh you're oh sorry yeah oh there you go
yeah okay
so i was gonna play this
obviously if it's a blitz game i would
just play without without thought right
yeah queen g6
queen f3 bishop g4 we need three and i
guess i didn't realize that this
position is totally winning because uh
the main point is that uh yeah bishop
visits a bishop the main point is that
black has three attackers on the king
side the queen the bishop and the knight
and white has really no defenders maybe
only the queen and if you watch gary
kasparov's videos on teaching chess he
always calculates that if you have more
attackers than your opponent on one side
then you have an advantage there but i
just didn't think about it
after a game but the main point is i'm
turning c5 and i missed after bishop a3
like i thought if my calculations like i
mean through takes d4 cd4 bd4
queen d4 bishop f3 g3 ato is through
eater but totally miss knight g3
you missed knight g3 yeah i forgot that
you could sacrifice one more piece yeah
yeah that's what yeah you actually got
all the way to this position yeah i got
all the way here oh what a pity and i
thought queen g4 e3 ah you got queen g4
trying to made him on the light squares
and you saw rookie three yeah and i was
like
i was like hey
i was trying to play normal played safe
and i was like hey i could be worse here
like i'm down the road
but do you think if that thought process
that a draw was sufficient to clinch the
grand chest or hadn't been on your mind
and you had that more killer instinct in
this position you would have been able
to find ig3 yeah definitely i think
yesterday i made several mistakes like
first of all i was too nervous thinking
about the result and all that i mean
obviously
winning the grand chester would be a big
deal again because you play all year
round also i think i was preparing too
much between
um
[Music]
but also maybe oh nice maybe it's just
not my day
but um
yeah it's hard to say uh
it's just
it's uh it's not so easy for me
sometimes to play irrational positions
even if they're better for me like
positions i've never seen before and
yesterday was unfortunately was one and
alireza's just
better than me at that on those kinds of
positions so
but it's not so bad like i would still
be happy to get a door on this game like
on move 21 she takes h3
and uh
you know i i saw rook e5 i was about to
play it
but i didn't i think after if i played
e5 but still wouldn't lose like he was
gonna play bishop c1
maybe queen h3 is possible but
roxy f5 is safe
and
he can play queen after if he wants to
win right but after rookie 8 i don't see
how black can ever be worse no it looks
like it's very safe yeah he said he was
going to play queen g4 instead of queen
of three yeah yeah but that's not on a
winning attempt right yeah take six
knight up six and then i think he was
going to play c4 right
did he say yeah in the interview yeah
big but c4 is not the best movie after
exeter is a draw i guess
we can have their c4 actually white is
slightly worse after knight g4 but
either way no no pressure on you wesley
when i think of you in the grand chess
tour i think of consistency thank you
you're so kind well i'm not kind i just
look at the numbers tell me what is the
secret
oh wait you always finish in the top
well i mean been playing granchester for
like six years
in a row
[Music]
i don't know i guess i
respect my opponent so much that i enjoy
playing against the
best players in the world um i love
watching you know guys like ian or fears
or magnus play
and
you know i don't mind playing rapid and
blitz also i enjoy those formats a lot
like remember 2016. i first i played my
first uh rapid and blitz like that kind
of format in paris in belgium you were
there i remember you
you're watching some fabulous games so i
thought the format is
the format of rapid and blitz is very
fun and
also you learn you learn a lot i mean
all the classical is much more serious
but i think the fact that you play the
same opponents over and over again and
it's a learning process
and you get used to them and it's you
know it's fun and exciting
and
i have years where i do very well
but you've won it before yeah
yeah i won before uh
well wesley congratulations on your
second place surely it's a good year for
you
yeah we'll see ya
well hopefully do better in the next the
next one but i must say also
congratulations to
alireth i guess he won the grandchester
he did yes yeah and probably ian wins
the thing
well we'll take a look as we keep our
eyes on this game it is the last game of
the tournament and of the grand chester
jan seems favorite to win the engines do
give him a decisive advantage wesley
thank you for joining us here in the
studio thank you wesley just uh one
quick question as you may very well be
aware
it's it's tragic story but i'm being put
to work
i'm being asked to choose the brilliancy
the tournament
and had you won yesterday in the style
that you were showing you would have
been a very clear favorite
of winning uh five thousand dollars in
the brilliancy prize
wait wait
yeah because you didn't
i've got to ask you uh help me guide me
i'm a i'm a judge along with peter but
what was the brilliant game
what are the choices
[Laughter]
yeah but i mean there are 40 games i
mean
what are you thinking the
game we were thinking uh ali reza versus
lavonne uh from i think it was round two
before yeah
what else
yeah exactly this is this is no i mean
that's that's interesting like alert
played perfect there and sacrifice the
beast
it was not perfect but it was a very fun
and exciting game yeah there was one one
particular move by alireza that was very
questionable and the rest was very good
yeah the thing is like
when the one played g5 the game was
pretty much over and alireza just played
very confidently sacrificing a piece
um
i let's see what what other games are
there
what other candidates i mean i could
name a couple
that's what we're asking you to do
i had it on a piece of paper but
there really isn't very much else apart
apart from that game i really don't know
where
it feels to me that jan is trying some
kind of a very very elaborate level
which kind of makes you makes you praise
alireza some more
uh
that was my feeling was about what yes i
was attempting to do but by the way yeah
we
mine was on screen alejandro's wasn't
but there is a bunch of surprise pikachu
faces in the studio right now because
the undeclined to take on h6
for reasons which uh i can only describe
his reasons
yeah maybe he just wants to reach 40 and
also
yes he has 50 minutes i don't think he
needs to reach 40.
[Laughter]
i'm not sure what's going on here and
the the prediction that jan will will
win this game has become a bit trickier
in the in the last five minutes i guess
if you think he's worried about rook g8
trying to drop the rook now yeah but
yeah we looked at this but even after e4
we thought the i mean he's just doing
great oh yeah probably e4 is very uh
yeah it's very strong once you see it
but it's also very uh
yeah yeah this is very concrete i guess
that's why we have yeah
yeah e4 yeah it's very clean so this is
the current position but now the rook is
in the sixth rank so you can defend the
pawn yeah the problem black has so many
double pawns
so many double isolated phones yes sir
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna force the
author to take this
we'll save that for the ultimate moves
wesley we have a number of people right
behind yeah
ready to come uh thank you so much uh
for joining us and uh congratulations on
your second place
the grand chess tour yeah thank you so
much to everyone who made the grand
chester possible to you guys also thank
you leslie thank you wesley uh okay we
are confused come on what is going on i
didn't yeah i really